bolloré bonsoir vincent bolloré bonsoir
je suis très heureux de vous avoir tous
les deux sur plateau parce que vu que
vous vous habitez nouméa et que vincent
est un manager qui réussit
formidablement bien qui est très occupé
c'est très difficile on va commencer par
toi là les gens est en train de se créer
c'est extraordinaire ce qui t'arrive
parce que d'abord tu réussis très bien
comme je viens de le dire mais surtout
il les gens tu prends une affaire de
papier à cigarette ça marche plus le
papier bible ça marche puisque vu
personne à l'église le papier carbone ça
marche puisque les photocopieuses avec 4
francs tu rachètes l'entreprise
familiale
tu fais 3 millions de pertes
2 millions de paires trois ans après tu
fais 100 millions de bénéfices face est
complètement extraordinaire tu est
conseillé de madelin tu rachètes l'asca
qu elle sophie calle de cmbf tout ça
alors tu es un peu l'image
quant au lit dans le journal vincent
bolloré le matin il veut à son bureau à
5 heures puis après il va prendre à 8
heures le petit déjeuner avec ses
enfants et puis il a une compagnie
aérienne mais il n'y a pas de chauffeur
enfin tu es tu vas la messe en fait
comme ça plein de qualité est un héros
moderne quoi mettre cette question je
vais te poser c'est est-ce que tu allais
des défauts ah oui beaucoup
d'abord les bretons sont tous têtu pour
mijade il faut éviter dans les années on
peut en trouver d'autres il suffit
d'aller demander aux personnes qui
travaillent quand il y en a beaucoup
ouais tu as tu un premier défaut c'est
d'être têtu sûrement oui deuxième défaut
sûrement trop gentil ouais on dirait
c'est pas un défaut de vous l'avez dit
pompidou mais non c'est vrai un peu
gentil c'est à dire je m'occupe beaucoup
de ce que font les gens et puis
troisième défaut je crois un certain
nombre de choses et j'essaie de les
appliquer coûte que coûte même quand
l'histoire on donne un peu tort pendant
la mythologie entrepreneuriale tu as un
peu remplacé bernard tapie j'ai un peu
un tapis clean quoi et qu'est ce que tu
penses de ta fille je crois que dans la
période
le problème c'est essentiellement
chômage pour chacun chaque chef
d'entreprise qui a fait même un 10
emplois d'attendre mieux pour mieux tant
mieux pour ceux pour qui la crée un
emploi dont tu te retrouves en a créé je
pense qu'il a fait aussi beaucoup pour
l'entreprise en général en importance
côté médiatique
donc je pense que son action était très
positive donc tu penses que le tapis et
avec des fréquences avant ce qu'il a
fait pour quelque chose de très bien et
que c'est très positif pour la france
qui l'a revalorisé il a contribué à
revaloriser poté entrepris chefs
d'entreprise et que c'est très positif
toi t'as un peu quand même tu es plus
rangée kuaté l'enfant chéri du cnpf
quand même lui il est pas trop aimé
quand même par les mecs du cnt je sais
pas si j'ai pas aimé par les débuts cnpf
d'abord moi je viens de rentrer au cpf
ça fait seulement six mois qu'on m'a
demandé d'y rentrer on sent bien avec
eux oui je trouve que ça prouve une
grande ouverture d'esprit prendre kezman
35 ans comme ça et c'est un endroit où
il se passe beaucoup de choses d'un
observatoire économique et social en
face à m'intéresser à des chefs
d'entreprise qui prennent des cours de
cuisine ou de claquettes mois cf sa
branche ça m'intéresse alors il ya un
truc moi que j'aime beaucoup chez toi
c'est que tu n'hésites pas à s'affirmer
catholique sociale sur sa fantastique
c'est moi je sais pas si je suis social
je suis catholique et je trouve ça
formidable parce que en fait tu
t'entends bien que les syndicats
finalement julie recettes
tu vas pas de problème tellement avec
les syndicats non on a je crois fait un
certain nombre de choses ensemble on a
aussi retrouvé devant une entreprise qui
avait des problèmes et ensemble on a
ramé du même côté et au même moment et
ça a été très positif et on s'est aperçu
que finalement si on était tous ensemble
dans le même bateau et que on
s'entendait bien ça allait mieux que si
on se disputer et donc ça a été très
posément compris cela tout à fait je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la crise a fait
qu'un certain nombre de gens sont rendus
compte que le problème maintenant c'est
et plus tellement de se battre entre eux
soit le coeur de l'entreprise
mais plutôt d'essayer de trouver des
clients nouveaux contre le concurrent à
partir du moment où on a fait cette
réalisation tout va mieux ce que tu
crois pas qu'au delà de la légende quand
même c'est vrai que tu as acheté la
sphère familiale avec 4 francs mais
quand même le fait que quand j'étais
petit il y avait des gens comme les
pompidou qui venait passer les vacances
ou les fêtes que vous étiez copains et
bernheim avec edmond de rothschild est
ce que c'est a aidé quand même pas
énormément je suis né absolument avec
beaucoup de chance de naître dans une
famille unie dans une famille aisée
et puis ensuite dans la reprise des
affaires que nous avons fait avec mon
frère et l'équipe avec qui j'ai
travaillé
nous avons eu la chance de profiter de
la hausse du dollar au moment où c'était
nécessaire
la baisse d'un certain nombre de
matières premières au moment c'était
nécessaire mais la chance existe je ne
sais plus qui disait la chance existe
sinon comment expliquer le succès de ce
qu'on aime pas que dans notre cas ça a
joué beaucoup
est ce que tu penses que ce qui se passe
en ce moment au niveau boursier c'est
grave
ah oui je crois que c'est enfin c'est
très fâcheux pour ceux qui ont investi
leur argent en bourse
tu crois qu'il peut tu crois qu'il peut
y avoir un crack réel je crois qu'il y
aura en tout cas un grand coup de tabac
je pense que ça correspond à une montée
brutale des taux d'intérêt qui font que
la plupart des gens se disent au fond
pourquoi prendre des risques en plaçant
notre argent en action autant les placer
dans les valeurs à revenu fixe 3
qu'aujourd'hui ça se présente pas très
très bien je suis confiant sur le moyen
et long terme
ta soeur quand elle était petite elle
écrivait déjà mais effectivement quand
j'avais pas fais mine sont mes a primé
le son fait mais pour m rédiger mes
rédactions
j'avais toujours des bonnes notes déjà à
l'époque puisqu'un générale dimanche
soir pour le lundi
il faut faire très vite vous avez publié
déjà un premier roman chez gallimard qui
s'appelait une saison folle en 86
ça a marché oui à vannes et celui là où
l'avait écrit là bas nous mais un
village il est écrit à nouméa mais on
pense un peu à la pratique c'est ça vous
sortez pas de la bretagne parce que tu
fais bretagne et rend seulement ta soeur
la bretagne c'est un peu une partie de
nous mêmes et c'est normal quand on est
entre nous on dans le programme mais
alors c'est quoi l'histoire du lieu
c'est un roman qui raconte deux ans dans
la vie d'une femme deux ans au cours
desquels tout arrive en même temps je
vois que c'est la peau comme ça dans la
vie elle est longue période calme et
plus d'autres qui sont des cartes
disposent war et les aiguillages dans
tous les sports et au début de
l'histoire on trouve marion tristounette
son mari l'a quittée pour une belle nana
et elle travaille dans une maison
d'édition c'est là qu'elle va rencontrer
grégoire deschamps qui lui est
dessinateur de bande dessinée et qui
présente le manuscrit de son premier
roman
mais il sait qu'il vous arrive déjà des
aventures comme ça votre frère ou à huy
pense que ça ne m'arrive pas il pense
qu'il sait pas si c'est autobiographique
où et pas vous n'avez pas des premiers
pas ce qui pourrait me dire moi non moi
je crois que c'est comme les rêves on
dit pour elle son autobiographie qui
veut pas ouvrir non ce n'est pas ma vie
et pourtant c'est pas par hasard que ce
soit vous qui rêvez vous
gigapan kristina bonnez assassiné
personne enfin se sent dépassée dira pas
mais vous écrivez pour quoi pour vous
occuper pour donner un
vous êtes à nouméa je sais pas en fait
je connais pas remarqué ce que c'est
peut-être passionnant non mais enfin
c'est pour vous occuper pour donner un
sens à ce qui vous arrive vous pour
laisser une trace dans l'histoire de la
littérature alors pas du tout j'ai
commencé à écrire j'ai terminé à c'était
pendant les événements si tragique de 84
et j'ai voulu faire quelque chose même
si ça a été l'impulsion initiale puis je
me suis dit il faut que je fasse quelque
chose pour la calédonie est oui j'ai
commencé à écrire et à décrire ce pays
que les gens connaissent pas tellement
finalement ça va continuer là est allé
enseigner autrement voilà est le
troisième roman que je ne ferai pas le
paso doble et hybrides actuels vanuatu
et on parle aussi de la nouvelle gamme
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou